I'm thinking about buying a restaurant
so I go and ask the current owner what
is the distribution of the number of
customers you get each day and he said
oh I've already figured that out and he
gives me this distribution over here
which essentially says ten percent of
his customers coming on Monday ten
percent on Tuesday fifteen on Wednesday
so forth and so on they're closed on
Sunday so this is a hundred percent of
their customers for a week if you add
that up and get a hundred percent I
obviously am a little bit suspicious so
I decide to see how good how good this
distribution that he's describing
actually fits observed data so actually
observe the number of customers when
they come in during the week and this is
what I get for my observed data so to
figure out to figure out whether I want
to accept or reject his hypothesis right
here I'm going to do a little bit of a
hypothesis test so I'll make the null
hypothesis I'll make the null hypothesis
that the owners owners owners
distribution owners distribution so
that's this thing right here is correct
is correct and then the alternative
hypothesis the alternative hypothesis is
going to be that is not correct that it
is not a correct and distribution that I
should not feel reasonably okay relying
on this it's not the correct I should I
should reject the owners distribution
and I want to do this with a
significance level with a significant
significant level of 5% of 5% or another
way of thinking about it I'm going to
calculate a statistic based on this data
right here and it's going to be a
chi-square statistic or another way to
view it is that that cot that statistic
that I'm going to calculate has
approximately a chi-square distribution
and given that it does have a chi-square
distribution with a certain number of
degrees of freedom and we're going to
calculate that what I want to see is the
probability of getting this result or
getting a result like this or a result
more extreme less than five percent if
the probability of getting a result like
this or something less likely than this
is less than five percent then I'm going
to reject the null hypothesis and or
that or I'm gonna which is essentially
just rejecting the owners the owners
distribution if I don't get that if I if
I say hey the prop
the probability of getting a chi-square
statistic that is this extreme or more
is greater than is greater than my alpha
than my significance level that I'm not
gonna reject I'm saying well I have no
reason to really you know assume that
he's lying so let's do that
so to calculate the chi-square statistic
what I'm going to do is I'm going to so
here we're assuming the owners
distribution is correct we're assuming
that the owners distribution is correct
so assuming the owners distribution was
correct what would have been the
expected observed so we have the
expected percentage here but what have
been the expected observed so let me
write this right here expect it I'll add
another row expected so we would have
expected 10% of the total customers in
that week to come in on Monday 10
percent of the total customers of that
week to come in on Tuesday 15 percent to
come in on Wednesday now to figure out
what that actual number is we need to
figure out the total number of customers
so let's add up these numbers right here
we have the calculator out
so we have 30 plus 14 plus 34 plus 45
plus 57 plus 20 so there's a total of
200 customers who came into the
restaurant that week so let me write
this down so this is equal to so I wrote
the total over here total ignore this
right here I had 200 customers come in
for the week so what was the expected
number on Monday well on Monday we would
have expected 10% of the 200 to come in
so this would have been 20 customers 10%
times 200 if on Tuesday another 10% so
we would have expected 20 customers
Wednesday 15% of 200 that's 30 customers
on two on Thursday we would expected 20%
of 200 customers so that would have been
40 customers then on Friday 30% that
have been 60 customers and then on
Friday 15% again 15% of 200 would have
been 30 customers so if this
distribution is correct this is the
actual number that I would have that I
would have expected now to calculate our
chi-square test statistic we essentially
just take let me just show it to you and
I'll write it
instead of writing hi I'm gonna write a
capital x-squared sometimes someone will
write the actual Greek letter Chi here
but I'll write the x squared here so
that it's it will be it and let me write
it this way this is our chi-square
statistic chi-square statistic statistic
and but I'm gonna write it with the
capital X instead of a chi because this
is going to have an approximately a
chi-squared distribution I can't assume
that it's exactly so this is we're
dealing with approximations right here
but it's fairly straightforward to
calculate we take for each of the days
we take the difference between the
observed and the expected so it's going
to be 30 minus 20 30 minus 20 I'll do
the first one color-coded the squared
divided by the expected so we're
essentially taking the square of almost
you could kind of view the error between
what we observed and expected or the
difference between the what we observe
an expected we're kind of normalizing it
by the expected right over here but we
want to take the sum of all of these
I'll just do all of those in yellow so
plus plus 14 minus 20 plus 14 minus 20
squared over 20 plus 34 minus 30 squared
34 minus 30
where'd over 30 plus I'll continue over
here 45 minus 40 45 minus 40 squared
over 40 plus 57 minus 60 squared
57 minus 6t squared over 60 and then
finally 20 minus 30 squared so plus 20
minus 30 squared over 30 I just took the
observed minus the expected squared over
the expected I took the sum of it and
this is what gives us our chi-square
statistic now let's just calculate what
this number is going to be so this is
going to be equal to I'll do it over
here so you don't run out of space let
me do this in a new color I'll do it in
the orange this is going to be equal to
this is what 30 minus 20 is 10 squared
which is a hundred divided by 20 which
is 5
I'm be able to do all of them in my head
like this plus actually let me just
write it this way just so you see what
I'm doing this is are going to be a
hundred this right here is a hundred
over twenty plus 14 minus twenty is
negative six squared is positive 36 so
plus 36 over 20 plus 34 minus 30 is 4
squared is 16 so plus 16 over 30 plus 45
minus 40 is 5 squared is 25 so plus 25
over 40 plus the difference here is 3
squared is 9 so it's 9 over 60 plus we
have a difference of 10 squared is 100
over 30 plus 100 over 30 and this is
equal to and I'll just get the
calculator out for this this is equal to
well this is equal to we have 100
divided by 20 plus 36 divided by 20 plus
16 divided by 30 plus 25 divided by 40
plus 9 divided by 60 plus 100 divided by
30 gives us 11 point 4 for 11.4 4 so let
me write that down so this right here is
going to be this right here is going to
be 11 0.4 for this is my chi-square
statistic or we could call it a big
capital x squared sometimes you'll have
it with written as a chi-square but this
is approximately this statistic is going
to have approximately a chi-square
distribution anyway with that said let's
figure out if we assume that it has a
roughly a chi-square distribution what
is the probability of getting a result
this extreme or this it at least this
extreme I guess is another way of
thinking about it or another way to say
is this is this a more extreme result
than the critical chi-square value that
there's a 5% chance of getting a result
of that extreme so let's do it that way
let's figure out the critical chi-square
value and if this is more extreme than
that then we will reject our null
hypothesis so let's figure out our
critical
a critical chi-square value so we have
an alpha 5% and actually the other thing
we have to figure out is the degrees of
freedom degrees of freedom and the
degrees of freedom here we have we're
taking we're taking one two three four
five six some so you might be tempted to
say the degrees of freedom are six but
one thing to realize is that if you had
all of this information over here you
could actually figure out you could
actually figure out this last piece of
information so you actually have five
degrees of freedom when you have just
kind of n data points like this and
you're measuring kind of the observed
versus the expected your degrees of
freedom are going to be n minus 1
because you could figure out that nth
data point just based on everything else
that you have all of the other
information so our degrees of freedom
here are going to be 5 it's n minus 1 so
our our significance level is 5% and our
degrees of freedom degrees of freedom is
also going to be equal to 5 so let's
look at our chi-squared distribution we
have a degree of freedom of 5 we have a
significance level of 5% we have a
significance level of 5% and so the
critical chi-squared value is 11 point 0
7 so let's go to this chart so we have a
chi-square distribution with a degree of
freedom of 5 so that's this distribution
over here in magenta and we care about a
critical value a critical value of 11
point O 7 so this is right here we
actually even can't see it on this so if
I were to keep drawing this magenta
thing all the way over here if I were to
just keep if the magenta line just kept
the distribution just kept going over
here you'd have 8 over here you'd have
10 over here you'd have 12 11 point O 7
is maybe someplace right over there so
that's it's what it's saying is the
probability of getting a result at least
as Extreme as 11 point O 7 is 5 percent
5 percent our result so our critical our
critical chi-square value so we can
write even here our critical chi-square
value our critical chi-square value is
equal to we just saw 11 point O seven
let me look at the chart again 11 0.07
is equal to 11 point O 7 the result we
got the result we got
for our statistic is even less likely
than that it's even less likely than
that the probability is less than our
significance level so then we are going
to reject so the probability of getting
that is let me put it this way eleven
point eleven eleven point four four is
more extreme than our critical than a
critical chi-square level so it's very
unlikely that this distribution is true
so we will reject we will reject what
he's telling us we will reject this
distribution it's not a good fit based
on this significance level